you don't you cannot make an economic
case that people are actually have to
have a credit card for survival today
that's just not true it's not they in
their brains they keep saying the
mathematical facts don't look at when
you look at their budget and you look at
what's going on and what they make and
what I mean everything in it it is it
what's hard is I'm like the math it is
tight it is hard but what happens is is
the standard of living that we're all
expected to live causes these things to
have to be a necessity in order to live
that standard of living and so to cut
to cut that well that means the average
American's living as stupid as their own
Congress is living well that they just
keep spending and spending and spending
like there's no tomorrow like there's no
Reckoning for this level of debt you
keep running up you got a trillion
dollars you got 1.7 trillion in student
loan debt you gotta now have a trillion
in credit card debt